tribes of Canaan. Of Canaan. Yeah.
Philistines. Yeah.
Notan. Yeah. Go on. Actually, not the
Philistines at all. And that was at the
time then when the Jews entered the the
land of Israel. That actually doesn't
apply for the rest of the time. Okay.
But the the wiping out of Amalcch does.
Yes. and the the the wiping out of those
people by by today's by today's land
don't know who the amal that's fine but
today's standard today's standard with
the wiping out of those seven tribes
from the land would that be considered
ethnic cleansing yes so so just on
record now you believe you are cuz our
religion doesn't have anything like this
absolutely anything like this no matter
how much people pay billions and
billions by the media to make Muslims
look bad we have nothing like this
killing babies hang on hang on hang on
hang on hang on my point my point just
say just say it on on on camera now that
your religion allowed or allows for
genocide and ethnic cleansing and you're
the only religion that I'm aware of that
has that as a tenant of faith from your
613 laws. It's not tenant of faith. It's
one of your 613 laws. One of the laws
yes. So genocide and ethnic cleansing.
Why? Because it was ordained by by God.
Yes. Okay. And what uh what and how can
you demonstrate? It's in the Torah.
Yeah. And how can you demonstrate that
the Torah that you have what you claim
to be the Torah? How do you demonstrate
that it goes back to Moses? I don't need
to. You don't need to. I don't need to
prove your rabbi say it and that's it.
But I can, but I don't need to prove my
claim to you. What's the point? No,
because if you're say if you if you want
to kill, let's say I'm a descendant of
Amalcch and I'm standing in front of you
now. Am I killing you? No. No. No.
Because you don't know if I'm a
descendant of Amalcch. If you if you
look, you have tussles on your corners.
Yeah. So you you you stick to the 613
laws. If I said I'm a descendant of
Amalcch and I was able to demonstrate
it, what would be upon you to do to to
do to me? So not necessarily. It's it's
a um um Don't go say say it's
metaphoric. It's literal. No, no, it's
lit. Literal. I don't say it's
metaphoric. Yes, it's literal. You wipe
out the seed of you erase his memory. It
is literal. However, there are a lot of
caveats within it. So, it has to be it's
um generally most um scholars accept
that that is in in the land of Israel
when the Jews have the power when when
there's a Jewish king. Yes. Which we
don't have at the moment. So for single
Jewish person it actually would matter.
Um however yes that is one of the laws
of the Torah and you have to go to
Ramba. That's right. And and to smash
the baby's head against the rock as
well. No that that is um that is not
the commandment that was given to Joshua
though. No no that was that that was
that is actually what also in in Psalms
King David says yeah to to smash the
baby's head against the rock and not
feel and not feel no mercy. No, no.
Vengeance is a great thing when when
when the baby when someone rises against
the the the people of God. Yes. We have
to take vengeance and smash the baby.
Smash their baby. Yeah. Smash their
baby. Can you see any parallel was
happening in Gaza today and the the the
the the commandments that you have? No.
You don't see that the these same laws
are being invoked? No. You don't you
don't see that? No. Am we will destroy
Amal Netanyahu said this himself.
This is the language that's being fed to
the idea of soldiers. Yes, it is. Don't
lie.
This is you. You told me earlier. Google
it. I'm going to You Google it now.
Sorry. Don't say don't lie. I I don't
lie. You No, but maybe you're
misinformed. Maybe you I think you are
because I've seen it clearly. You have
generals. You have people claiming that
listen, this is Amalch. We're going to
wipe them out. Netanyahu himself says
this. Maybe. What do you mean maybe?
Everybody's seen this except for you and
you're telling me that we that I'm not
that you're that you're correct saying
anything. What you're doing is like you
have to do you're not allowing me to
finish. Is that what you're saying?
Yeah. Go on. Now you're being rude.
Mocking me. Go on. Let me finish. Go on.
What did say? He invoked the biblical
verse. You should wipe out the And who's
mentioning that biblical verse? Wipe out
the the seed of Amalc. And he applied it
to who? Hang on. You're not going.
Arguably um you could say which why I
think it was he meant was Kamas.
However, um that's a policy. That is
just a rhetoric in a in a speech. This
is the rhetoric. This is the same thing
that George Bush said, "We're going to
go on a crusade to Iraq." This is the
language that the people are using
that's in the back of their minds when
they're fighting. So, this is the lang
whether you say policy or not policy.
This is all semantics. This is all the
enemies of the Jewish people. I mean, I
said listen what you mean enemies of the
Jewish people. The Jews lived in
Palestine way before the Zionist
entered. How can you say that the Jews
are the enemies when the Jewish golden
age was under the Muslims? The Jews
flourished under Islam. I I've said that
before. Anyone anyone who rises against
the Jewish people, it is the moral duty
of the IDF to wipe them out completely.
You have no right. You have no right as
IDF. Israel doesn't have a right to
exist, let alone to defend itself. The
Jews, however, have a right to live in
Jerusalem. This is my belief as a
Muslim. The Jews have a right to live
there and a protective status there, but
they don't have Israel doesn't have a
right to exist, let alone a right to
defend itself. That's like that's like
someone asking me does does ISIS have a
right to defend itself? It's not a
state. It's not a legitimate state for
it to be. No, no, no. It's it's not a
state where where it's not a state that
has a right. It's your fine. That's
fine. When you enter a land and you and
you hold the positions that you have as
a as a rabbitic uh Torah observant Jew
and you live side by side with people
believing that you can take their
wealth. I mean there's something you
keep pretending you talk about rabbitic.
Israel is a secular country. No no no.
Do I have the right to alia?
No. Why? Why? Yes. Why? Why yes? Okay.
Why? Why don't I Why do I have the right
to what? Huh? Alia to to return back to
Israel? Do I have the right to become a
French citizen? Huh? I don't know. Are
you French? No. Okay. So, so why don't I
have the right? What what is the right
dependent on in Jerus in in Israel?
Automatic right is if you're Jewish. If
you're Jewish and how do you find Jew?
Well, um it it is a secular country that
has adopted some Jewish practices. Um
for example, how you define Jew? They so
they define Jew according to to to
rabbitical law. Rabbitical. Hang on.
It's a secular country. that for for
this for their status quo, for their
base laws, they've accepted a few uh
Jewish um ideas. Really, the right to be
a citizen in Israel is dependent on you
being Jewish. Hang on, hang on, hang on,
hang on. The
definition that's fine, right? You can
become a citizen. No, no, fine. No, fair
enough. The definition of a Jew, okay,
you have two claims, a historical claim
and a religious claim. The definition of
becoming a Jew, all of the historic
claims go back to a religious claim. How
is a Jew? What is a Jew? Where did you
get the definition of a Jew? It's from
the Torah, from the Tanakh. It's is it's
it's
religious. So, you're using secular when
it suits you, but you're based on
religious definition. Completely secular
countries. People like Ben Shapiro have
mentioned this. We are religious Jews
using secular arguments for secular
people. So, listen listen. Complete
secular country. It was founded by
secular people. bas upon religious
definitions. Yes. Religious definitions.
The right to return is based upon a
religious definition. The right the a
Jewish state. Yeah. What is Jewish is
only based upon religious definitions.
So this discussion is this why this why
I differ with any this why I differ with
my my like people when they when they
argue with Jews. This is not a political
discussion. This is not a discussion on
secularism or this country or that
country. It's a religious discussion.
It's a religious discussion. secular
country founded on secular ideas using
religious definitions and religious
premises they had to use some kind of
definition and there was a lot of
argument debate at it at its inception
uh for example when the day of rest is
going to be what the the symbols should
be um what should define a Jew etc
various things that were and what did
they look to and well they looked for
for a lot of them they looked at where
did they look to where did they look to
they looked to history to president to
to the many Jews who came there and
after back lots of back and forth It was
decided that um these kind of ideas who
is a Jew day of rest and some other
things are going to be decided by um
what the religious law religious
religious law however these are just
these things that were set at the time
as the definition of a Jew at the time
in a secular country but it's still a
secular country secular ideas secular
government and Tel Aiv is completely
secularist town but they don't they
don't apply in any way shape or form How
how are the Jewish the Jewish the Jewish
people that wanted to make Israel? Okay.
What what held them together? What bound
them? Was it their DNA? No. What bound
them was was the shared history. The
shared history of of where of the Jewish
people and and where and how is that
defined? The Jewish people. As a Jew,
it's defined by the Bible. The Jewish
people are both a tribe, an ethnic
group. Yes. And a religion. Yes. So you
can join Judaism. can join the Jewish
people, but you're also automatically
Jewish. Now, the Jews having been
persecuted in exile in the diaspora for
many, many centuries, they were distinct
tribe, a distinct ethnic group. So, even
though based upon what though? Well,
actually at that point for the vast
majority of the founders of Israel just
based on their ethnicity, just based on
their tribe. But how was the tribe
defined? No, they were defined by the
non-Jews. They're defined as belonging
as having been born from this group.
They're not they're not religious. How
would they define themselves? How would
they define themselves? Parents were
religious parents. I know I know but
they use religious definitions. They use
religious definitions that all the other
nations use. Someone put
someone said you were born even from a
Jewish father which is not in the Torah.
Nazi Germany used you birth and this is
how they were seen by all other nations.
Grandfather or something. You could have
one grandfather and you would just that
was in Nazi Germany. But that is not
that is not um under Jewish law. But no
but in in so so so they went they were
seen as Jews by all the other people. So
therefore they they saw themselves as
No. But what how did they how did they
define themselves? Again they defined
themselves as Jews because they were
based on everyone else. No no no. Don't
try and tell me that no. You don't want
to listen. That's fine. That's fine. I
don't I'm not listening to that. No. I'm
telling you now that the definition of a
Jew was coming from the mother, okay?
Was based upon religious law. This is
how you know who's a rabbi, who's a
Levite, and who's not. Okay. Levites is
from the father. Okay. But you know who
the tribes are. The tribes tribes are
from the father. Okay. But you but the
the Jewish the Jewishness is
from the mother. Exactly. But you know
your tribes. You know your Jewish. Hang
on. Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. You know
this. Tell me why Israel. You know this
secular state was found on secular
princip you know this from the religious
text. What's your point? My point is
that this is a religious discussion. Are
you saying are you saying Israel is a
religious state founded? No. I'm not
saying I'm not saying on religious
principles. I'm saying that there are
religious principles underpinning it.
Yes. Absolutely. When we see Netanyahu
himself taking uh lessons and advice
from the Lubovich as his main guide
before he was in the UN, we know that
this is a a religious motivation. This
is religious motivation. When he quotes
Amalcch, which is found in the Bible,
knowing the 613 laws, one of them is
quoted. Hang on, hang on, hang on, hang
on, hang on verse that Israel is found.
I never said that. I never said that. I
said I said it's underpinning it. I said
it's underpinning it. Not even not
underpinning it. Guided by it. I'm
saying it's underpinning it. Is not
guided by religious laws in any shape or
form. Listen, you admitted earlier that
it is secular. Um when it's it's it's
secular but has a religious uh they use
religious definitions. There's some
religious flavor. There's historical
Jewish flavor. It's more about history.
No, no, but this is what this is what
underpins it. No, it doesn't. It is. It
is. And I'm explaining why. I'm explain
why. I mean it's like saying that that
that values underpin the British values.
But Britain is a secular country. Why?
Why that land? Why that land? Why Israel
had that land? When they've been offered
Uganda, they've been offered Why that
land? Yeah. Why that land? Because it
was a Jewish homeland for 1300 years. A
Jewish kingdom. Where does it say that?
We had it. History says the history. And
when you go back to the history, the
history is self-defined by religious
tens. Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Hang
on. That's fine. That's fine. But
though, but we know now that when
they've done DNA studies, the
Palestinian Arab Muslim shares more in
common with the Mizrai Jew than the
Ashkanazi Jew. How is it? I don't think
that's true. This is this is DNA
studies. Maybe you don't like DNA
studies, but that's not Jews are most
their closest relative is the Sicilians.
Any so so we know that there were 12
tribes. Uh there were lost tribes. Those
lost tribes, they became enveloped into
the surrounding tribes there. They never
left. They're still there. They're the
descendants. If you do the DNA of a
Palestinian, he's going to have some
safic or some Misrai or some Yemenite.
They're going to have The question is is
is complex and yes, it's a mix of of
religion and so why that land? Why that
land? That land is because it's the
Jewish homeland and it's nothing to do
with was it promised to the Jews? It's
got nothing to do with being promised to
the Jews. It's got nothing to do with
being promised. If if you if you look in
the in the declaration of independence,
it says very clearly because this is
where our whole identity was shaped when
in
when 1900 years ago 1900 years ago our
identity was shaped. We had a kingdom
spanning 1300 years that is a long time.
So do you believe that our identity was
shaped? Now this is this was a secular
declaration that God isn't mentioned at
all. And in fact what is mentioned is we
call upon the the Arabs to stay here on
the basis of equal citizenship because
they did not want to exile any Arabs.
It's only the ones who wage war they
they lost
their secular country. Do you believe
now that a people who have maintained
their identity but over 1,900 years but
have come from a different place? Do you
believe they have a right to that
original place? For example, the Irish.
The Irish they're said to be Kelts that
originated from Anatolia and Turkey. Do
you believe the Irish have a right to
return a right to claim the land in in
Turkey? Is is Turkey sovereign country
nowadays? Turkey is Yeah. Good. It
wasn't a cultural is that wasn't
cultural. That was genetic. Yeah. But
was it why does it have to be cultural?
What's that's what the whole point of
the hang if the
Irishity if the Irish their Celtic
origin that Kelt is said to come from
Anatolia. Celtic is not one group
though. That's fine. That's fine. But
they said to migrate from through from
through Europe from Anatolia. Do they
have a right to go back to Anatolia?
It's not just Anatolia. It was actually
also north. If you get the semantics of
it, do they have a right to go back to
Anatolia? That matters if they're
going sovereign. Do they do they have
Okay. Anatolia and everywhere else on
the way. Is Turkey sovereign? Well,
again, it's not their culture. So, no, I
would say no. Is Turkey sovereign? Is
Istanbul sovereign? Is Turkey sovereign?
Is Ian Bulan? No. Sorry. Is Bodram
sovereign? No idea what that is. Bodum
is one section. one one area of of
Turkey is is does it belong to Turkey?
It belongs to Turkey. Okay. It's Turkey
sovereign country. Turkey sovereign.
Great. Palestine wasn't Turkey.
Palestine. The the British mandate of
Palestine to give it its full name was
the administered um area by the British
mandate. And before that it was a
colony, a Turkish colony. And before
that was a colony of other countries all
the way back to the Roman colony because
it was always a colony. Ever since the
Romans expelled the Jews, it was always
a colony, never sovereign because
Israel, the land of Israel, the holy
land, never gave itself away to become
sovereign for anyone else. It was always
an administered colony. It was waiting.
Where did you get this idea that the
Israel never never gave away? It was
never
sovereign. Israel is all the way back to
history. Ever since the Jews were
expelled, it was waiting for its people
to come back. It never became sovereign.
Show me one time in history when it was
sovereign. It was always a colony. So,
so the Romans when they had minister, it
was a colony. A Roman colony. So, so the
Romans controlled Israel. Yes. Okay.
That was a Roman colony. It never became
sovereign. No other nation ever made its
place there. It was always a colony of
someone else. That's not true. Yes.
Kingdom of the Kingdom of
Jerusalem. That was an independent
state.
The kingdom of you know that wasn't the
crusade. Yeah. But it wasn't in the
colony of the Vatican. It wasn't a
colony. It was an independent state. All
right. It was a ruled by foreigners, but
it was it was a papal colony. So So why
do you believe the Jews were expelled
from uh Jerusalem by the Romans?
Personally, as a religious Jew? Yeah. As
a religious Jew? Because God God wanted
to expel us. Why? God, what did you do
in that land? Why did he expel you? What
What have you done? What did you do?
Between us and God. What do you mean
that's between you and God? You're
you're you're you're you're expelling
people from their land and taking their
land back. Yes, you are. Yes, you are.
Huh? Israel is a state that you're
defending. Expelling who? The
Palestinians. That Palestinian. What do
you mean? No. No. No. No. Don't do this.
It's happening. It's happening. There's
no Listen. What's known doesn't need to
be said. What's known doesn't need to be
said. Palestinians are being What's
known doesn't need to be said. I'm not
even entertaining your semantics. You're
doing a lawyer stuff now. What I'm
saying to you is because you're No, no,
no, no. So, no. There's no fault. Why
were you expelled from Jerusalem? It's
irrelevant. Why? Why? It's It was God's
will. What was it? It's irrelevant.
Previously, when you were expelled from
Jerusalem, what had happened? Was there
some sin? It's irrelevant. Was there
some sin?
It's irrelevant because this is where
the crux of the matter is. Not really.
The the the the land that was given to
the Jews was under the condition that
you serve God alone and you submit to
him and you do not sacrifice your
children, you do not sacrifice the false
deities and you put God first. What
happened? The rabbis came. They they the
Jewish pe people they committed child
sacrifice. Every time a prophet would
come to them and say stay away from
child sacrifice they killed the
prophets. Okay? Like Amos, like Isaiah,
like uh I can't remember the there's a
few other ones as well. Every prophet
that came and told you stop doing child
sacrifice, you killed. And I will go on
record and say and show demonstrate that
if needed is irrelevant. That's that's
that's the reality. Then what happened?
You began to take your rabbis as lords.
You have in your Talmud the the the
tandoor of Aknari. You'll know what I'm
referring to. The tandur of Aknari where
the rabbis said one thing and one rabbi
alone said something else and the bat
the voice of heaven came down and said
the truth was with that rabbi. The
rabbis here said it is not in heaven. It
is with us. So you believe that the
rabbis have the authority to to to
to legislate law and that God has no say
in the matter. So if now God so if God's
will if God now said to you if God now
revealed to a prophet somewhere and said
I am the prophet of God. He gave you
signs and miracles and wonders and all
the evidences he needed to demonstrate
that he is a true prophet of God and
that prophet said to you that this is
the law from God and it contradicted the
belief of the rabbis. Who would you
follow? We know but I just want you to
say it was absolutely if a prophet said
if a prophet went against the Jewish law
which and by that by that includes law
that in itself is proof that he's not a
prophet. Okay. And then when I asked you
earlier proves he's not a prophet. Okay.
And when I asked you earlier what is the
proof that the rabbis have the
authority? What is your proof of your
Talmud going back to Moses? Then you
then you said relevant. So this is the
issue. It's not relevant to you. It is
relevant to me. It is relevant to me. Do
you want to be Jewish? No. No, no, no,
no, no. I'll tell you why. It's I'll
tell you why it's relevant. Because when
you claim something that is true as God
would want it, you need to have proof in
your scripture. It says, I'm pretty sure
that Israel is not claiming I'm not
talking about Israel. I'm talking,
remember, I'm talking about me
personally. I as a religious Jew, I
don't need to defend Judaism. You don't
need to defend it because if you did
defend it, you would have no leg to
stand on. I do, but no, you have no leg
to stand on. I know it. Don't tell me
it's an assertion because you don't know
what you believe. You might have
everything. No, that's fine. That's
fine. I've looked at the evidences, the
main evidences for the belief that the
Talmud and the Torah, the oral law, the
the the the halaka is from God. And it
comes down to a few chains of
transmission that they have. One of them
is called the the ethics of the fathers
that they have. Who wrote the ethics of
the fathers? You don't know. I'm sure he
doesn't know. That's fine. I'm not
saying you're Jewish, but I'm saying no
one knows who wrote it. Okay. So, now we
have Who wrote it? Who wrote it? I dare
you to say who wrote it. I'm not
interested. Educate me. Educate me.
Launched it. There you go. There's
nobody knows who wrote this. Nobody who
wrote no. What are you talking about?
Ethics of the fathers of the fathers was
written by who? Ethics of the fathers is
one track date of the mission. Written
by who? The entire Mishna was compiled
by the the Rabbi Judah the Hanasai.
Judah had Judah Hanai. Yes. Was compiled
by him. It was the teaching of the
rabbis. Probably roughly half of the
mission have the names of the rabbis.
The rest of them were almost all of them
written by Rabbay. We all know it's not
it's not a big secret.
Rab wrote them. So who wrote who
compiled it? I mean no no you don't
know. When is when is the earliest copy
of the Talmud then? I have no idea.
Excellent copies. I have no idea. Oral
tradition. 13th century. 13 11th
century. I think it's Len Leningrad
Codex if I remember correctly. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. So that's after Islam.
That's oral tradition though. So all the
oral tradition came before? No, but the
oral tradition was meant to be written
down before Islam.
Again, just because we had the earliest
we have it from there doesn't mean
that's not debating. No, but if you want
to establish that it's it's correct, you
need to a way to substantiate it. If you
can't do it through manuscript, huh?
Because you're saying God's God is
pleased with the rabbis uh legislating
their law and God is ple Yeah. You're
you're when it when it says, for
example, smash the baby's head against
the rock. If I'm before I smash a if I'm
a rabbitic Jew and if I'm a rabbitic Jew
and I'm going to smash a baby's head
against the law, I want to know that
that's from God. Does that that say the
Torah? Smash Smash the baby's head
against the rock and do not. It says in
Psalms in Psalms. Yeah. Yes. That's not
the rabban. No, no, no, no, no. I'm
talking about all of the Hang on. I'm
talking about all of the law. I'm
including the oral and the written. Are
you an orthodox Jew? No. Why does it
matter to you? I'll tell you why.
Because when I see somebody about to
smash the head of a baby against a rock,
okay,
like and and and they tell me that we
have religious
legis and I'm stopping them. That's what
I'm doing now. Now you're talking to me.
Yeah. Okay. Now, you're the one that's
justifying Israel's actions in Gaza. Are
you stopping them? I'm I'm mentioning
what I'm saying. Okay, great. Yeah.
Okay. So when I see somebody about to
smash a baby's head against a rock
believing he has religious justification
from God. Hang on, hang on, hang on,
hang on, hang on. If I'm hypothetical
situation, there's we can't think of any
situation where we see uh people doing
it in in the name of Hang on. You're
cutting me now. You can't see any
situation where we can see repeating the
same nonsense cuz you're not letting me
finish. You're not letting me finish.
You're you don't like this subject.
That's what it is. So let me just finish
the point. My point is that's fine. I'm
stupid to you because I'm a boy. Because
I'm a boy or what? You hear the subject
then? That's fine. Hear the subject
then.
Absolutely. Absolutely. So when I'm
seeing a person smashed the head of a
baby against a rock and he believes he
has religious justification from him and
I ask him for where's your chain of
transmission for how do you know that
this is from God? How do you know this
is from David or how do you know that's
from Moses? And he tells me ah we have a
chain of transmission in the Talmud.
This is was passed down from from our
rabbis. That's what I'm picking up.
That's what I want to show. But hang on.
The rabbis entered something. You you
mentioned Rabbi Mir earlier. There's a
narration that mentions anything that
has no uh uh no no source, attribute it
to Rabbi Mir. Anything that has no
source, if you want it to stick,
attribute it to Rabbi Mir. So when you
said, "Yeah, we know Rabbi Hanai, he's
the one who compiled this. We know Rabbi
Mir, he's the one of the main." Why
Rabbi Mir? You mentioned Rabbi. Why?
Because any statement that you find is
from the stim. You know the stamatim the
people the unknown the unknown
statements anything that is unknown
attributed to Rabbi Mir this is a famous
thing with Islam now anything from any
prophet whether it's Moses whether it's
Jesus whether it's David there must or
prophet Muhammad wasallam there must be
a chain of transmission so this is what
I'm I'm I'm I'm a chain of Islam does
not have a chain of transmission we
absolutely have a chain of transmission
that's why you have to learn from us
that's why you have to learn from us to
Muhammad chain of transmission to to
Muhammad and if Muhammad wasn't telling
the truth if he I know you forget lying
let's say he was mistaken then it all
comes back to one mistaken person and
that's that's the problem with with
train chain transmission to one person
our chain of transmission goes back to
my father's father's father's father my
friend's father's father's father's
father all of our people's father's
father's father's father you know why
it's so wrong what you're saying because
your chain of trans
your chain
of the chain of transmission that you
have the chain of transmission that you
have goes to one pe one person. It goes
back to Moses to Joshua. It does the
same thing. It's the same thing. That's
why you have that's why you have
hang on. That's why in your chain of
transmission in Abad you have the Zujot
the two the two the pairs. You have
Shimon the righteous and you have
another one. You have uh Rabbi Benhei
and Rabbi Benhag. You have these two
people. So you have two people in the
chain that we don't know nothing about
and you're saying all these people at
Mount Si. No, you don't have all these
people's transmissions at Mount Si. Your
point is that you believe his point is
that you believe it's not about that.
It's I'm critiquing you. Exactly what
Allah mentioned in the Quran. You've
taken the rabbis as and monks as priests
and lords besides Allah. So you believe
so you believe. So you believe that if
God was to say something now and your
rabbis were to say something else, just
say it on camera. You would follow the
rabbis. Just say it as they did in this
in the in the in the tandoor of my
mouth. No, you believe in the Talmud.
You want to I can say my own statements.
I don't That's fine. The the tandoor of
a where the rabbi said one thing and the
other rabbi was alone but the voice of
God said we're going to support him and
they said it is with us not with them.
We don't care about the bat. And what
did Elijah allegedly the prophet Elijah
met met a rabbi later on and what did he
say? What he was asked of of Elijah,
what did the holy one what did God say
when that debate happened? And what did
God say? Let you tell the people God
said God is smiling and says my my sons
of have won me in in debates. Allahbar
Allahbar something that to that I don't
know translation. So so your children my
children have defeated me. Yes. So your
god, our God, the one who created all of
us and and knows everything, knows the
past, knows the future, knows what would
have been and what has has been, he was
defeated in a debate by the rabbis.
Absolutely. Yeah. So this is where we
end
it. You have no chain of transmission
from Moses. You follow your rabbis and
just remember the promise of Allah. It's
not your strength as as Jews. It's not
your strength. It was our weakness. The
moment the Muslims come back to Tohed on
mass, you will see that we will be able
to stand and you won't be able to take
our lands from us and you won't be able
to kill us. And just to to mention now
before anyone claims I'm anti-Semitic,
our mother Safia was the wife of the
prophet Muhammad. She was a Jewish, she
was of Jewish origin. When some of the
other wives of Arab descent, they mocked
her for being Jewish. The prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him returned to
her and said tell them that my she was a
descendant of of a she was a Levite
descendant of a daughter of a Levite. He
said tell them that your father was a
prophet meaning Harun. Your uncle was a
prophet meaning meaning MS and your
husband is a prophet meaning Muhammadam.
So what we say is that the Jewish people
that follow what Moses was upon and
follow what Harun were upon. These are
people that are beloved to us and it is
nothing to do with hating them for
ethnicity or loving them for ethnicity.
The best of you in the sight of Allah
are the pious, not the ones from any
state or any religion or anything like
that.
So, but just know that the promise of
Allah will come to pass and is our
weakness, not due to your strength.
Allahbar is
God is Jewish and he was and he's
defeated by the Jews and he's defeated
by the Jews and and you beat and your
rabbis beat God. This will be your own
undoing.
forchech.